So we all know that theaters have struggled this year
but now, Variety reports
that in just five days,
the new release of "Godzilla versus Kong"
made almost $50 million at the box office.
Wow, $50 million.
Yep, and these days, that is a feat.
It's the only movie to do anything close to that.
It sold all those tickets
even though people had the option
of watching it at home on HBO Max simultaneously.
And the big event movie apparently is not dead.
And this summer, we've got so many big ones coming up.
Check this out, the slate is hot.
"Cruella."
Can't wait for that.
I mean, Emma Stone is just everything,
so I'm already there.
Also "Space Jam 2."
Which I know you're so excited about.
My kids love "Space Jam," we love "101 Dalmatians,"
so these two, we are definitely hitting.
And then I am also so excited about "In the Heights."
This is the one I cannot wait for.
If you haven't seen the trailer, you guys, google it.
It'll give you chills.
Yes, it gives me chills.
And so I mean, I think this is a good sign.
I think movie theaters wanna come back in 2022
but I think the game has forever slightly changed.
It's completely changed
because just like this, this Kong movie,
people went to the movie theaters
where they're open to view it
but it was available.
And I think movies are gonna have to do that.
Stream at home if you want to,
but go back to the movies.
And I will tell you this.
I was thinking maybe I don't need
to go to the theater again
but just the idea, you guys,
thinking about smelling that popcorn
and paying $20 for Red Vines.
I'm kind of missing that.
That whole experience.
I don't miss the prices of the concession stands.
I think that needs to take a deep look into itself.
Seriously, like with this economy,
should not charge these prices.
Yeah, I will admit, it has turned me into a criminal
because I have popped my own popcorn
and snuck it in a duffle
and I know, I know, I'm a bad boy.
I mean, I've taken my kids
and checked out and it's like $65 at the concession stand
and I'm just like for some cokes and some popcorn
and for some Red Vines
and I just think it's too much.
It's too much.
Can I ask though what is your go-to at the movie theater?
What do you get at the concession stand?
Well, I used to love whipping my friends
with Red Vines 'cause they hurt.
(Ross chuckling)
That was a fun prank I used to play on my friends as a kid.
I love the concession stand,
I just want families to not feel price gouged when they go.
Totally, agreed.
Hey, we've got even more hopeful news
in today's Green News.
(audience cheering)
(Drew banging)
Okay, now I have never been to Venice, Italy.
Have you been?
Yeah, I wanna go so bad.
Everyone that goes there falls in love
and now CNN reports the historic city
has finally banned cruise ships,
which apparently was like a big deal.
Cruise ships have a big footprint
and activists have fought for this for a decade
to protect Venice from further erosion and floods.
An alternative terminal,
it'll be built outside the city
and for next steps, climate activists hope
it'll include plug-in power technology.
So when a cruise ship docks,
they can totally cut their emissions,
which is great news for a historic city.
I can't wait to visit.
One thing I wanna admit right now
is that I love cruises.
I know, I know, I'm that person.
I'm all about it.
Okay, I love unpacking ones,
and every time you open up your window,
if you can afford a window,
you are in a brand new space.
I love a floating buffet
but I do feel guilty about the footprint,
so I love that they're doing this.
When the pandemic started,
the air in Beijing had cleared out
and the dolphins were back in the canals of Venice,
we could see the improvement
when we backed off a little bit.
So I'm so grateful to the cruise ship industry
and everybody who fought for this.
This to me is the kind of hope that we really need.
We need to see this action
and then that inspires us as individuals
to do our part 'cause I know,
for the last 20 years, I thought what is my part gonna do?
It's all the things.
It's the industry's and the individual's.
And I think this a way of how we'll never go back
to normal but the new normal,
we can just be armed with such knowledge
of what we know now, right?
Yeah, so check this out.
The NCAA Women's Championship wrapped this weekend
with Stanford taking the title.
Yeah, Stanford.
And at the championship game,
People Magazine reports
that the University of Arizona coach,
Adia Barnes, was able to fit in a quick pumping session
during halftime.
No, I don't mean working out.
She has a six-month old daughter
who was hungry at the game
and a sideline reporter named Holly Rowe,
shared this behind-the-scenes detail
and said quote, "For those of you who think
this is too much information,
let's normalize working mothers
and all that they have to do."
Absolutely.
This story really spoke to me, Rossy.
Well, yeah, I mean,
just proves how incredible women, mothers are.
They can multitask like crazy.
I can do like half a thing at a time
and here she is like a real quick timeout,
I'm gonna go feed my child mid-game.
It's amazing.
I mean, I just have to say,
my deepest, deepest respect
and I'm just amazed at women
and we all know how we got here,
so thank you for all that you do.
Yeah, I just hope the basketball coach
didn't spill 'cause that would be a double dribble.
(both chuckling)
(upbeat music)